so don't don't lean forward with the way
on front foot so we're both in a in a
mutual stance I now bring
over covers the
about
releases and LIF and he enters he should
feel comfortable he should be 50 on his
feet I watch him as he holds me
off and and then I cut here slightly
around this way then this means it will
cut my whole head
off if we don't do that if I if I Just
Step
straight if I Just Step straight this
what happens and it only
mix and this is incorrect so when he
pulls back to the
now throws out all all the
measurements okay so he releases
me
so so these are the points that are
important we'll just change
camera Okay so
so it doesn't matter who adjusts as long
as we get to this point here okay so I'm
going to like letting air out of a
balloon this is the feeling soft
sof what's the front foot it it operates
throughout my
body it doesn't it doesn't just lift and
then I start step forward I'm connected
all the way through my
body comes here and I adjust the back
foot ijust the ijust
the and I
cut he covers the wrist he releases the
wrist I lift and I watch
him and I watch him and I step slightly
round and that's what makes
the the can go through my neck on the on
the swords work when he slides back now
he moves his body not just his arms
again this needs to be
controlled okay he releases
me I he can step back but normally it's
a slide back but it might be a big slide
back and you get this problem
so it means in this case he wasn't
connected um sens sensory wise because
if he had have been it would have been
like a piece of
string it would have been like a piece
of string pulling him